[Music]
look at that smile
northie is turning nine on june 15th and
along with her mama kim kardashian the
two are sharing a sneak peek inside her
birthday bash on their joint tick tock
account
[Music]
and if you're wondering who that
character is with the moves well it's
kuromi that's the theme north went with
this year a sanrio character from the
fantasy magic melody animated series
let's go there's an epic club this way
there's north having some fun with her
mom as she and kim toss stuffed karomi
bears back and forth and check out this
cute shot of north's little sister
chicago and cousin dream snuggling up
next to karomi for a picture plus plenty
of clips of the birthday girl showing
off all of her caromy themed merch
[Music]
that laugh says it all clearly northie
had a great time but to be honest we're
somewhat surprised she didn't go with an
encanto themed bash
it's like her world
after all she is a huge fan of the viral
track we don't talk about bruno
[Music]
no
we don't
and we could have definitely seen north
doing a tick tock themed party to have
so many
options she's proven so many times what
a big fan she is of the social media
platform
[Music]
but years before north and kim started
blessing us with their wacky vids etsy
learned kim's firstborn was making
videos on a secret account north has a
private tick tock account so we we do
lots of tick tocks together she puts
them in drafts
she's not allowed to post them but we
have lots of tick tocks i might post one
soon and posting one soon has now
evolved into the mother daughter duo's
shared account that boasts nearly 7
million followers
[Music]
cheers to northey turning nine and
hopefully giving us lots more of this in
the year to come